how would we cut the Cartesian equation
from this out of these guys have a think
what you do it's a bit of a weird
example you might need to speak back to
when we did auxilary angle the Cartesian
equation this we can get from the
parametric equations up here so see how
X is defined as cos theta and Y is
defined as sine theta like that so so
these are the parametric equations for
the unit circle all I would do is I
would square this and square this like
see I'm gonna have to square them right
so x squared will be cos squared Y
squared will be sine squared now what do
I do with those you just add up the left
hand side so that gives you this and you
add up the right hand sides which gives
you this you see how it comes out so I'm
just trying to highlight that for you
because parameters are not a we'd crazy
idea you've been dealing with them for a
long time you just haven't met their
names okay now I'm going to return to
these probably in period three or four
for after we reviewed the tuned exam
these are very specific we I didn't give
them to you by coincidence I gave them
to you because they landed right here
there are lots of different parametric
equations that will land on the same
Cartesian equation so I'm going to show
you a bit later on in period three for
why we choose these ones but for now I
just want you to get comfortable with
the idea of parametric equations as
compared to a Cartesian equation so can
you go out open up your textbook
we're in nine D
and have a look at question 5
okay now we're gonna skip right along
the first few questions in this exercise
are really they're pretty rudimentary I
sort of already talked you through the
basic ideas so we're just going to jump
right in
I just showed you a few minutes ago how
to convert from parametric equations
equations which have parameters in them
like these guys into a Cartesian
equation an equation with no parameters
to be seen so have a look at this let's
name them shall we what would you like
me to do if I wanted to get towards a
Cartesian equation unity okay great so
if I find that T here if I make T the
subject then that makes it really easy
to pump it into here and the parameters
going by such a point then we just need
to simplify a little bit so let's do
that with equation one what will I do to
make T the subject what exactly will I
do yeah I think I'll add two to both
sides I'll subtract X from both sides so
that gives me T equals three takeaway X
all right and this can go straight into
equation two
so when you have a look at this
how's that look happy with that you can
see that parametric equation is
depending on how you write them can give
you a cycle can give you a parabola can
give you a straight line in fact pretty
much any shape you can come up with can
be expressed in terms of a parameter why
would we do this well like I said we're
gonna come back to this one which is the
primary reason we're interested in this
can you have a go at V but has some trig
in it which is similar to what we had a
look at here with the unit circle what
could you do with it the way we approach
the unit circle and turns its parametric
equations into a Cartesian equation the
way we did it here will be helpful to
you so have it got B and if you've got
an idea call me over that's one way to
go that's an overall strategy that we
usually try however I would point out
that the problem with this is so on the
weekend my daughter had to make a
diorama of the solar system okay she's
in year three yep and so she had to
paint a box black because it's space
right so she's painting and that should
get someone to fall now I said to her
okay well you got to clean this up now
right and so what did she do she goes
and gets like baby wipes cuz she knows
that's what used to like clean up rain
himself and as she does that there's
like you know there's paint it's like a
gold paint here right and she like gets
the baby wipe and then she's like like
this like and then she picks up her baby
wipe and then she looks at the paint and
it's like ten times bigger than what it
was before right and did you like hmm so
I said you took a little bit of paint
and you've gotta made it a lot of paint
so for those of you who are trying to
turn this for example into sine theta or
cos theta
like okay but now you have to theatres
to get rid of not one okay so it's not a
bad idea but what you'll find is it's
probably more trouble than it's worth
okay okay so here's my suggestion to you
at an overall strategy here which will
help you with your trig identities as
well because in some ways this is just
the trigger
problem it's just not dressed up as the
normal kind of left hand side right hand
side okay it's a little more obtuse to
try and work out I want you to remember
what happened over here okay we know
that we can get sines and cosines to
cancel out with each other
so long as they're squared right why is
it that this square that makes it useful
to us what fact can we use we can use
the Pythagorean identity right namely
that sine squared plus cos squared
equals one you remember this well
there's a whole family of these
Pythagorean identities this one just has
sine and cos but there's one which has
ten and SEC in it as well how do I get
from this one to that one what do I do
to this whole thing because I never
remember what it is which one's plus one
minus one I'm going to divide by cos
squared right so when I do that what
this turns into is ten squared plus one
equals
okay good so my aim is to try and use
this thing now when I have a look over
here I've got ten there I've got sick
there but they kind of muddled up with
all this other stuff so how do I get
away from there well let's give these
names you probably already have what I'm
gonna do is before I square equation one
I'm not gonna do that just yet because
when I square this I'll get one I'll go
I'll get four ten squared theta but I'll
also get four tan theta in the middle
there right so it's like what I was
suggesting we're sort of related to Y
with my daughter and her pain it's like
it just starts to go everywhere okay so
the real problem is because there's two
things here on the right hand side it's
a binomial so that's why when you square
it you get more and more terms just like
we know in binomial theorem so if it's a
problem having two terms over here let's
just not not have two terms there like
it's the same equation yes but clearly
this is going to be de better to deal
with because when I square both sides
now which is what I'm gonna need to do I
don't get more theaters turning up one
term on the right-hand side being
squared is still one term
so now let's square I'm not even going
to expand this guy because I do
I'll get very much out of it okay what
do you think that look okay I could
divide through by four as well because
then
oops I don't need the extra bracket
there then I've just got a single tan
squared theta and I know what I can do
with that in a minute
okay so let's call this guy 1a what
shall I do with two like I can do a
similar thing I can get rid of that 4 on
the right hand side by adding it to both
sides which gives me that that's a
really Missy for sorry okay there you go
and now when I square y plus 4 squared I
might as well divide through while I'm
at it
how's that are you happy with that so
now I know that this plus one equals
this right so I can say let's have a go
at this one a plus two and what are we
going to get I've got X minus one all
squared on for y plus 4 or squared on 9
equals now I want you to note this
because I did this wrong but I can fix
it and you can help me do it right when
I do this because adding equations
doesn't seem like that bad an idea
it worked over here right I get this
statement which is true but it's not
very helpful
can anyone see why yeah look I don't
have 10 squared plus x squared in this
identity right I suppose if I were to
rearrange it I would have tan squared
minus SEC squared so this is no good no
problem this happens all the time you do
something you're like oh I've hit a wall
so you just back up a little bit and say
well maybe the subtraction is a better
idea right yeah that also works like I
said there's there's lots of different
ways that I can go through this so yes
that would be I mean it's gonna amount
to the same thing I think but that's
fine I'm just gonna do what means less
writing for me so now that's equal to
what what's that equal to look carefully
that's negative 1 isn't it right
so I've got this 9 equals negative 1
do you agree now I probably do one more
thing just tidy this up I don't like the
fractions there so I can multiply by
something to get rid of all the
fractions 36 will do it so that'll give
me a 9 here and a 4 here equals negative
36 as I sound